as the great Lionel Richie once said all
night long all night if you're not into
epically long late-night grinding
sessions than this epic game between
alpha zero and stock fish may not be for
you but on December 6th 2017 the match
went down between alpha zero and stock
fish and this was game eight a
positional affair similar to the start
that we've already seen a few times if
you've watched the video reviews of Game
three and Game five we're assuming that
you have if not click the links and go
ahead and do that here again we see
Bishop to b7 game 3 featured the move
Bishop a6 buy stock fish game 5 featured
the move Bishop to b7 and here the
mainline Queen's Indian approach with
Bishop to e7 not satisfied with his
results stock fish chooses to vary it up
us mix it up once again with Bishop to
b4 check and after Bishop to d2 Bishop
e7 Knight to c3 you see that one of the
main reasons why black actually gives
this check and then waste that tempo is
to put the bishop on d2 you might be
thinking why right why help somebody
develop a piece ever well the main
reason is that and if you've seen the
other two games you know that most of
the time White's threat to push the d5
pawn is based on the compensation
White's gonna get on the D file and in
this case when the bishop is on d2 as
much as it's already a develop piece
it's actually kind of a common
positional trick if you will in this
line that the bishop is not necessarily
on its favorite square on d2 so this is
all theory and in this queen's indian
after the move c6 e for d5 the position
you're seeing has been played many times
by the world's best chess players
you name it Magnus Carlsen Vishy Anand
pavel Eliana if those are just some of
the names we saw as we as we prepared it
and looked at this position but every
single one of those players had one
thing in common in this position they
all played the move he takes d5 this is
the main idea for white in this line
normally to capture and after C takes d5
put the knight on e5 you're building
pressure in the center taking advantage
of what is now a pinned d5 pawn due to
the tactics there and white goes on to
have a slight edge and in most of these
middle games based
on the the fact that the tension here
favors white when we say tension favors
one side it usually means that one side
has the luxury of building up on that
tension because it has the option to
capture whereas the other side can never
really break the tension at least not
with serious tactical or positional
consequences so that's what that means
when you hear the tension favors
somebody there's a quick chest proach up
so that's what we were expecting the
whole world when you see this position
played the mainline Theory being e takes
d5 but alpha zero had something else in
mind
played the move e5 which though not an
official novelty that only happens after
94 castles castles is the official
novelty alpha0 played this position has
already been played only a few times so
we can already consider ourselves in new
roads given that alpha zero did not play
e takes d5 as we said most of the
world's best grandmasters play and
usually the move e5 is followed by C
takes d5 specifically because you're
trying to create this tension here and
once again you're trying to eventually
maybe take here have double pawns you
can play against or again have pressure
on a diagonal where as long as the
structure remains the same black's
bishop may not be as good as the white
counterpart
however again alpha zero has something
else in mind he castles and after Bishop
a6 you may see some of the reasons why
white doesn't normally go for this line
because you're kind of in a position
where no matter what you do that c4 pawn
is now going to be lost and due to the
fact that it's pinned to the rook on f1
alpha zero doesn't have a lot of options
for saving it and and therein lies the
the mind blowing I guess again another
mind blowing pawn sacrifice by alpha
zero in this match
he plays b3 not because he intends to
take back on c4 and just be down upon
but because he intends to give up the
pawn with the move before officially we
are in uncharted territory where the
first the first thing you think when you
look at it is okay if this is such a
simple approach by white why have
another top grandmasters play it you
start to think black must be able to
hold on to this pawn and if he can do
that that's a healthy pawn why isn't
black doing fine the problem here is
that the positional features
specifically the weak dark squares
followed by a very direct assault from
alpha zero
make it pretty clear where whites
compensation is and suddenly you might
be you might be seeing lines like this
played by top grandmasters before you
know it if alpha zero can do it why
can't we
top chess players will likely be saying
after B for threats of a4 and b5 and
threats on the diagonal or a problem
so black decides I'm gonna stop that
with b5 and why is that not a good idea
to anchor in my protected passport and
once that knight comes into e4 we see
that the natural approach of assaulting
on the dark squares is is gonna be
pretty pretty fun for White Queen rg4
played first because who doesn't like
threats on f6 check and maybe I'll Bluff
at an attack but after the move Knight
to d7 you see my intentions are very
clear as white I really just want to
play nice e5 force in exchange because
you don't want to drop that Bishop and
with it likely to c6 pawn to follow and
we look at a structure where everything
is equal besides two things black has
the extra C pawn but White has them much
much much much much can I add another
much more dominant Bishop and we're
seeing that human types of analysis or
let's say abstract evaluations who has
more space whose pieces are more active
right and really who is the ability to
create threats right that's a practical
way to look at stuff but if you have the
ability to improve your position that's
worth a lot right and alpha zero
certainly thought it was worth upon even
though this line has never been played
before and we're gonna see over the next
series of moves
maybe I tricked you by saying that this
was an all night long
Lionel Richie session which it is it is
a grind fest like no other but I don't
know that there's a lot more to look at
other than white is going to grab the D
file use the space advantage that that
he again deepmind that it has and black
is gonna be basically playing shuffle
puck until white decides where and how
he wants to infiltrate a5 is exactly
what you want to do you want to try to
undermine and give yourself space but
these immediate threats are really
nothing white sparing them one by one
here comes Bishop before and we're just
gonna start pushing them back push him
back to pieces that's exactly what white
does over the next series of moves let's
induce another weakness hit age 7 so the
g6 has to be played and when we back up
the lady now we have other ways to
create counter play so without without
try
to overdo the picture that black has
nothing to do here I'm gonna overdo the
picture and say that black has nothing
to do here
the c-pawn being the biggest advantage
is not going anywhere and likely doesn't
even have access to a good Snickers bar
it's just it's doing nothing and white
will be able to poke and prod wherever
you want build up on the H file maybe
Bluff at opening things up and going to
sac town maybe I switched over to the a
file of course a strong player like
stockfish is not going to just fall prey
for any sort of force combination but as
that builds up and the pressure gets it
gets more on the king's son and more on
the Queen side that balance and that
inability to deal with it because if you
switch to guarding the a file then it's
just the D file that becomes the other
place that White is playing tickle with
including the H file right so Black has
really just sort of stuck to sitting
tight and noting highlights that more
than after Queen e7 that alpha0 played
Queen to f6 let's look at what would
have happened here if the Queen trade
had happened because I already analyzed
it after takes and takes I had to
consider this because knowing that alpha
zero really brought the heat on the H
followed that when the Queen's remained
on the board I'm thinking why didn't
stock fish take this chance to trance to
shade transduce rate after Bishop a8
rook h1 we're gonna see that white has
white house all the cards here name a
square that black can move to without
losing material name a move that can be
made g5 allows h6 and this pawn will be
picked off with a weakness taking here
allows rook takes and this pawn is gonna
fall with with likely with interest and
a mating net black is just sitting tight
and nothing emphasizes that more than
let's say a line like okay I analyzed
age six first because it really shows us
tight but to be clear
probably Brook a one is even more
accurate because black is not going to
take here no reason why we're worried
about that let's go to the a file first
and force the rook trade now we can
either take on g6 or play h6 by the way
I think both wind to the clear plan
we're gonna highlight which is that once
the bishop comes to e5 it's only a
matter of time before our King
infiltrates we filled the d6 square not
at a Keable piece due to what the D pawn
will then do to you the King comes in to
e5 and give that evaluation bar
three-to-one and it just keeps going up
over there on the left side of the board
because there's really nothing black can
do to the capture the King infiltrates
and you see this is a great example of
where
human I knew this position was an easy
win for white as soon as I said it right
I guess what was that like back here or
even before Queen takes f6 because I
look at this and my human perspective
says black has no squares and if the
rooks come off the board this
infiltration of the King this is this is
good
Russian endgame stuff 101 right there's
nothing black can do moving the bishop
off would drop the C pawn and with it
everybody else so again alpha zero is
having clearly a deeper understanding
he's seeing beyond the horizon the the
computer knows via its machine learning
it's self-taught approach that the that
the win is there even before stockfish
does and and nothing is more fascinating
I think than sing the world's strongest
engine outplayed by by something that
can we even call it the world's
strongest engine I don't know um you
know why alpha zero is still playing
chess and why it hasn't you know just
said hey you know what I don't need you
guys anymore I'm gonna learn how to walk
or something I don't know so queen of
six is played and black doesn't take on
f6 backs up the Queen but we're gonna
see that the grind fest continues
building up on the H file taking when
it's most convenient because now I have
other tactics that can come on g6 and
and building up with the F pawns
marching again black doesn't really have
any squares the Queen offers the trade
then a little bit better for black there
because at least the bishop would have
some squares so white says no thank you
some tickle is played here but the point
is it's not tickled without a reason the
threats of Bishop g5 Bishop f6 and then
even ideas like taking g6 where we clear
the way for crushing attacks that type
of fret forces black to play c3 which is
now making its only positional advantage
vulnerable no longer protected right so
it's like every action is an equal one
opposite opposite reaction at first c3
like well why did he play it knowing
that in the next few moves alpha zero
simply Corral's that lost calf and and
now we really like White's position
because you're not even down material
but you see that there really wasn't a
choice because of other Lacs you know
lack of options right and and why having
some concrete threats like bringing the
Bishop to g5 so we continue along this
path of playing very patient moves very
disciplined moves of course II five not
capturable due to the fact that d8
hanging f4 now comes we put the bishop
on f6 with the weaknesses that have been
induced there's no way that black holes
to those even if the f6 pawn falls and
that's exactly the kind of thing that
white points out grabbing the a file
this is this is like Anatoly Karpov
chess you know this is like Anatoly
Karpov having a fantasy right and right
next to him is wróblewski and things are
getting weird in that bed you know what
I'm talking about Bishop takes g6 rook
d7 king of two and again we look at this
position with clear understanding that
white is crushing black right dominance
of the dark squares pieces that can't
move and pawns all along the color
square of your favorite everybody's
favorite Bishop at this point and that's
what happens here black just has to sit
tight I start sacrificing pawns in the
way that only computers do no human
would ever play h5 but a computer sees
it as the same loss either way because
the computers like well I can't just sit
here and allow this to come but of
course h5 is it like no human would ever
just give you a past H pawn right so it
does change it up a little bit cause it
gives black that counter play but it
only is a matter of time before now the
c6 and the b5 punt fall and white goes
on to to just win with the Queen side
and finally here stockfish does just for
sine strange how stock Fischer decides
when to resign and when not but I'm not
here to try to pretend to think like an
engine I'm here to try to help us human
beings understand why the engines did
what they did and I hope that I've done
that for you and that you maybe have
learned something please leave a comment
here regardless of where you are
watching this check out our video
library on twitch on YouTube wherever
that is
I appreciate you tuning in for what was
of course game 8 and the epic match that
was between deep mines alpha 0 and
stockfish